Brooklyn and what this does for Phoenix
well first you know great information
from Chris and I want to shout out
Charles because two weeks ago you sat on
this stage and said this will be the
biggest trade deadline in the history of
the NBA and I looked at you and I'm like
what is he talking about I honestly
didn't believe you and when it started
happening you know I was like you did it
Chuck you said it you called it I think
that that's incredible uh you know the
amount of players that have moved and
obviously the biggest piece was you know
Kyrie and and Kevin which snowballs
everything because uh this is the first
time in the NBA there's probably seven
or eight teams who said we can win it
typically there's two or three and so
when those two teams made the move to
try to win it the other teams have to
follow they have to make smaller moves
big moves or whatever uh you know you
might say what it you know Kevin Durant
is a big move but you know I'm just
going back into even to when
our era when Mario Ali came to our team
people didn't think that was a big move
that was a guy who helped us win an NBA
championship in a big way he played
multiple positions and he was a key
member of that that can be like a Jay
Crowder to Milwaukee move 100 it could
be what PJ Tucker was two years ago with
the uh when you know as well so those
guys kind of can make differences that
you might not realize make the biggest
difference the biggest takeaway here
there's no quiet there is no quiet move
there is no loud move there's just moves
and people would like to say it or not
say it
um the the biggest piece to me is the
Los Angeles Clippers because they have
no guards on there no point guards on
that roster right now so with with
moving Schroeder so the best destination
for Russell Westbrook is the Los Angeles
Clippers because he fits in and he
doesn't have to do B Russell Westbrook
or get 20 points and triple doubles he
could be in and being and Tyrone Lou is
a guy who can really coach and really
handle yeah they added Eric Gordon to
that mix they got bones Highlander yeah
I know and uh and who's and also Mason
Plumley to back up zubots well
all that's well and good I still think
Denver I'm not going to disrespect the
Nuggets I think they're still the
favorite
I think the two big winners were my
Phoenix Sons and the Los Angeles Lakers
shout out to robalinka you know he he
hasn't done a good job the last couple
years but in the last two weeks he's
really made a huge difference in the
last two weeks where does this put
Phoenix Shack in the in in terms of a
western conference title on the paper it
definitely puts them in the discussion
and you know in my opinion it is a
championship of us here but Kenny you
know we talk about little moves and you
know I love the others that Jay Crowder
to Milwaukee it brings toughness it
brings God conducting you know defend if
you know it brings to God that's a great
team player and it's a guy that can hit
a clutch shot in clutch movements I like
that move I'm gonna be paying attention
to them but back to your question it put
some up there in conversation but I
think they have to get it done this year
Kevin's getting older Chris is getting
older and now with the mid-range Mafia
that's what they call now they're going
to be very very dangerous offensively I
didn't like them giving up young fellow
because he was a great you know
defensive player but Michael Bridges yes
Mikhail Bridges but you know offensively
they've been very potent and if those
two guys can play together and and play
with high efficiency they're going to be
very very dangerous to be I think to me
the key for my sons is going to be the
the guys they release because
Chris is older but you got two guys KD
and Booker who are two of the best
offensive players in this league
we haven't even mentioned DeAndre Aiden
yet yeah he gonna benefit playing with
those guys but I really need to see a
list who do you still do you have
campaign coming off the bench you got TJ
Warren who they picked up with Durant's
been hurt as well but but and that's not
going to get it done they don't need
because Ernie
the West is so good now you're gonna
need a good you can't go to war
with just KD Booker and Aiden because
the West is so loaded if they play the
Clippers the Lakers now haven't even
mentioned Memphis your bench is going to
be it really really important so the
bile market like Chris says they gonna
have and they're gonna have to get some
big bodies you just mentioned campaign
he's a little guy TJ Warren's a smaller
guy he's about six six seven there but
I'm talking about after that they gave
up a lot so I think the Bob Market I'm
gonna be watching that for my sons our
starting unit we're good to go but to
win three series just to get to the
finals your bench is going to be huge
he's setting a record for saying my son
one hour an hour and I was about to say
alive broke the record for hours
oh my God got the purple shirt on too
boy hey man Phoenix is on fire right now